last i think official game of the day
against ana music
uh who i think is one of the coaches
of the challengers teams
and uh she's also been one of the
very best female players of of the last
10 years
and um has several world championship
titles in
in rapid and blitz so let's get going
i will continue with the rule lopez
there will be a couple of unofficial
games after this
so the show will not be be stopped
immediately but this is the last game of
the competition but i think
team polgar is already
has already one won it so he plays this
a bit trickily
i'll go h3 i'm waiting for b5
before determining where i go with my my
knight
because i may want to go to b b3 there
later on
now i probably have to go to f1
since she did a good um
job of uh waiting sufficiently
and like usually when d5 comes you would
go b4 and then knight to b3
but um obviously here with the knight on
f1
such a plan would be more time consuming
and then
probably uh less successful
so i'll go eat a4 instead as i did in
one of the other games
i need to meet b4 with with a5
and now here
think knight g3
she can't go d4 at any point she can
also
exchange on on um
on e4 probably take with the knight and
then the pawn
and play play a queenless middle game
which i think could be slightly better
for white at least
i'm clinging to the hope so b4 is
logical but now she is
opening up for a possible
possible bishop a4 so it's a little bit
double-edged
okay d4 let's go knight e4
if she trades everything i think i'm
fine with that
i believe a5
is probably a bigger strength than a
weakness
in the ending now
so normally you would go rook d1 without
thinking what could be more natural
than that but i do think maybe
maybe bishop d1 is more precise because
i want to put the bishop on e2
and pressurize a6 and also if i'd gun
rook d1 there could have followed rook
d-8 and then if bishop d3 there's bishop
c4
and additionally if i trade on d8
it's not so easy to bring the bishop to
d3
and if bishop e3 then she could trade on
on d1
so i think maybe it's more clever to
keep both rooks
on the board um
now yeah rook d8 i followed my plan i
got bishop e2
obviously i don't think i have much here
at all uh but
the possibilities that something will go
wrong i think are slightly higher for
for black since
um if i lose the a5 pawn that's bad for
me
but if she loses uh a6 then it's
it's a disaster uh so music is a very
well educated player and she immediately
spots
a nice positional plan here which is to
go knight c82 to d6
and that probably probably equalizes the
game more or less
but maybe not maybe not completely i
still have some ideas like rick b1 and
then knight b3
i should have gone rook b1 immediately
maybe but i can still protect c3 so it's
fine
okay let's bring the king a little bit
closer
can never hurt if f5 i go king e1
f4 i'm not so sure about it may just uh
cement e5 as a as a backwards pawn
and c6 i don't like at all i think she
she is over protecting the knight on c
on b5 uh but she is leaving a pretty
glaring weakness
on the b6 square which i'm now using to
invade i'm psyching the pawn on c3 but i
don't care about that since i want to
invade
now rick d7 i should be winning king f6
there's bishop d8
and here there's a little trick with
bishop c7 if rook chase
g uh sorry uh bishop g7
rook g7 and then take on e5 and c3
and then the um the bishops will decide
as i talked about on another
stream bishops on adjacent diagonals are
very strong